thank you very much thank you thank you
that's a wonderful ovation for our last
show of the season ladies and gentlemen
and what a great night to be here for
the last show because President Obama he
did it yesterday made the big speech on
immigration he said he said if you like
your gardener you can keep your gardener
no he signed the big executive order
protecting four million illegal
immigrants from deportation or as Fox
News reported it president Black Panther
unites minorities against whites
and correct you know he got his really
giving it to the B did it at the
beginning of the Latin Grammys this is
like if you went at the Country Music
Awards and gave everybody a truck you
know so Obama he's now done immigration
he's done gay marriage his approval
rating may be in the toilet but it's a
hundred percent with Ricky Martin I'm
telling you that please
of course Republicans are taking it well
they're in a snit like I've never seen
before they're gonna do fun they're
gonna impeach they're gonna shut down
the government they're gonna sue him it
is literally a Mexican standoff at this
point which is crazy because he
purposely reached out to the Republicans
in his executive order it says
specifically these Latinos who by the
way pay taxes do jobs nobody else wants
to do okay they're not gonna get health
care benefits no Obama care for them not
gonna get welfare benefits no voting
rights no unemployment benefits so he's
saying to conservatives hey guys we're
still being [ __ ] just not as big an
[ __ ] as we used but doesn't matter
they're so paranoid Michele Bachmann
said these illegal illegal immigrants
she said they're gonna be voting okay
there's no evidence of illegal
immigrants ever voting although they
should there's another job Americans
won't do
I mean the one place of lagoons do have
a little gripe is that a couple of years
ago Obama talked about doing this and he
said I can't do this because I'm
president I'm not King and now he's like
you know what any of you [ __ ] don't
want to do this I said I was gonna do it
if you didn't you're always sitting
there in Congress going he's not my job
and he did it but of course you know
John Boehner is talking about Obama's
acting like a king
that's right Obama's a king and John
painters at night and his name is
cirrhosis of the liver now he Boehner
says Obama has damaged the presidency
and today Hillary said I'll take it
anyway uh he's a king he called him an
emperor all last week he's an empress it
he's an emperor who forced amnesty down
our throats at least Bill Cosby used to
at least give you a roofie first
oh it was kind of a bad week for the
cause let's take a look at the Bill
Cosby tote board and see how many women
are up there now no it was kind of a bad
week for Bill Cosby on the plus side he
has lots of pills lying around that can
make him forget the whole thing
really you're on this guy's side okay
well even Las Vegas canceled his show
when you're too sleazy for Vegas I think
that says something you know and I'm
always on the side of innocent until
proven guilty I get it celebrities are
targets but 16 women all with the same
story even for a guy who did a sitcom in
the 80s that's a lot of wacky
misunderstandings I mean
sorry but this guy is such a creep I've
had to reevaluate everything I ever
thought about and what I used to think
hey whatever happened to that
malcolm-jamal Warner and now I'm like oh
my god whatever happened to Malcolm
Jamal Warner somebody dig up Cosby's
basement I think he's buried in it I
don't think it is ironic justice that a
nation of black teenagers now gets to
say to Bill Cosby pull up your pants